durante su vida matemática se
encontrarán en situaciones donde tienen
que redondear números y ustedes se
pueden preguntar bueno qué tipo de
situaciones serían estas pues en
situaciones en donde ustedes tienen que
obtener un estimado de algo o tal vez
tienen una medida y quieren ser un
poquito menos exactos para simplificar
las cosas sin importar qué tan exacta es
la medida aquí vamos a pensar de qué se
trata esto del redondeo vamos a
redondear cada uno de estos números 36
34 35 26 y 12 redondeamos cada uno de
ellos a la decena más cercana y les voy
a dar una pista de lo que esto significa
en esencia es tomar cada uno de estos
números y encontrar el múltiplo de 10
que es más cercano a esta cantidad
cuáles son los múltiplos de 10 10 x 0 0
10 x 1 10 y es por 2 20 10 portes 30 10
por 4 40 y así sucesivamente los invito
a que pausa en el vídeo y ustedes traten
de encontrar cuál es el múltiplo de 10
más cercano a cada una de estas
cantidades
para analizar esto con más detalle vamos
a poner una recta numérica acá manu de
hecho son dos rectas numéricas que las
estoy poniendo acá y tratemos de
encontrar en donde se pondría cada uno
de estos puntos en esta recta comencemos
con el 36 donde va a estar aquí bueno
pues va a estar entre 30 y 40 aquí
tenemos el 35 esta marquita azul así que
36 va a estar un poquito más arriba de
esta marca más o menos por acá aquí está
el 36 y si nos acercamos más entre estos
dos puntos entre el 30 y el 40 es 330
este es 40 donde va a estar el 36 bueno
a esta marca azul es 35 aquí en las
siguientes 36 esto de aquí en verde citó
es 36
si queremos redondear a la decena más
cercana o al siguiente múltiplo de 10
más cercano
cuáles son las dos posibilidades seca
bueno puedo tener 36 y redondearlo hacia
arriba al múltiplo de 10 que está por
encima de él que es 40 lo puede
redondear arriba a 40 o lo puedo
redondear hacia abajo al múltiplo de 10
que está por abajo de él que es 30 así
que lo puedo redondear hacia abajo a 30
ahora necesito encontrar cuál de estos
números es más cercano a 36 bueno al ver
en la gráfica podemos ver que 36 está a
sólo cuatro unidades de distancia del 40
pero está a 6 unidades de distancia del
30 así que vamos a redondear lo hacia
arriba al 40 y esto se llama redondear
hacia arriba veamos los siguientes
números vemos el 34 y aquí los invito a
que ustedes pasen de nuevo el vídeo y
piensen en qué número se va a redondear
ese
4 hacia arriba o hacia abajo
bueno 34 está aquí lo estoy marcando en
rosa 34 aquí y en esta ampliación raíz
de 4 va a estar acá donde lo estoy
indican 34 y tenemos de nuevo dos
opciones el múltiplo de 10 que está por
encima de 34 que es 40 o el múltiplo de
10 que está por abajo que es 30 a cual
está más cercano pues solo está a 42
lugares de distancia del 36 del 40 así
que está más cercano a 30 por lo que
vamos a redondear hacia abajo a 30 y
ustedes me pueden decir oye cuando
redondeamos hacia arriba 36 llegamos a
40 se incrementó la decena por lo que
para redondear hacia abajo el 34
deberíamos de incrementar la de sede y
llegar a 20 pero no 30 es el múltiplo de
10 que está por debajo de 34 así que
cuando redondeamos hacia abajo se
mantiene el múltiplo de 10 pero las
unidades se vuelven 0 ahora veamos uno
que está más interesante pensemos en
cómo redondear el número 35 a la decena
más cercana antes de intentar hacer esto
veamos cuáles son las dos opciones que
tenemos
35 estar aquí en este punto del medio
aquí en esta ampliación 35 va a estar
acá de 35 podemos redondear lo hacia
arriba a 40
o hacia abajo a 30 nuevamente los invito
a que pagos en el vídeo y piensen en
ello pues aquí no queda claro hacia
dónde podemos redondear porque está
justo a 5 unidades de distancia del 45
unidades de distancia del 30 por lo que
la comunidad matemática ha decidido
definir qué hacer en este caso si
tenemos cinco o más en las unidades se
debe redondear hacia arriba
esta es una red 5 o más en las unidades
implica que tenemos que redondear hacia
arriba aquí en el 36 este 6 es mayor que
5 por lo que redondeamos hacia arriba
redondeamos al 40 aquí este 4 en las
unidades es menor que 5 por lo que vamos
a redondear hacia abajo hacia el 30 esto
nos da una muy buena intuición sobre qué
hacer en estos casos ahora veamos el
número 26
escribimos el 26 cuáles son nuestras dos
opciones cuál es el múltiplo de 10 que
está por encima de 26 y cuál es el
múltiplo de 10 que está por debajo de 26
el múltiplo de 10 que está por encima es
30 y el múltiplo que está por debajo de
26 es 20 si lo redondeamos hacia arriba
llegaremos a 30 y si lo redondeamos
hacia abajo llegaremos a 20 bueno para
redondear a la décima más cercana vemos
el lugar de las decenas y después nos
fijamos en las unidades las unidades van
a decidir hacia dónde vamos a redondear
vemos que esto es 5 o más grande que 55
o mayor por lo que vamos a redondear
hacia arriba así que 26 lo redondeamos a
la decena más cercana que es 36 es mayor
que 5 por lo que se redondea hacia
arriba bueno ahora qué pasa con 2 yo
creo que ustedes ya están entendiendo
mejor esto pues veamos el múltiplo de 10
que está por encima de 12 es 20 y 12
están justo por acá así que lo vamos a
redondear hacia arriba hacia 20 o lo
vamos a redondear hacia abajo hacia
bueno recordamos que tenemos que ver las
unidades vemos que aquí nuestras
unidades son 22 es menor que 5 y ya que
es menor que 5 pues vamos a tener que
redondear hacia abajo hacia 10 y además
tiene sentido porque está más cercano a
10 son dos unidades de distancia de 10
así que redondear 12 a su decena más
cercana va a ser 10